well i do welcome this announcement
today from the home secretary i've been
speaking to on a daily basis over the
last few days working out what we can do
to restore the shuttle
people across the country uh have and
the announcement today means uh we'll be
looking to firstly what happened in
relation to this serving officer
who was able to abuse his power
to abduct sarah average
and unfortunately rape and murder her
uh see if any opportunities that were
missed
to make sure those are addressed an
accident taken
and then the second part of the inquiry
is to look at wider issues raised
from uh these shoes that we're hearing
about on a daily basis now
of misogyny sexism racism and homophobia
and i make this point the vast vast vast
majority of police officers are
incredibly brave men and women who run
towards danger asking us to go to safety
but we can't escape the fact
that the confidence the british public
have in the police has been shattered
uh by the awful uh sarah the situation
will happen to sarah her murder
the home secretary referred to said so
the public will have the right to know
what systematic failures enabled his
continued employment what's wrong with
the met
well i think it's a problem not just in
that police service but we look at what
happens across police and many of us
felt shocked betrayed in a sense of
shame when we heard the details in
relation to not just uh sarah's
abduction
uh uh rape and murder but also the fact
that this police officer apparently had
had allegations made against him at kent
police
in the civil nuclear constabulary he
appears to have passed the vetting
procedures he appears to in a whatsapp
group
have been sharing frankly speaking
offensive uh homophobic racist sexist
messages with other servant police
officers and so there are all sorts of
issues that need urgent answers to
that's why
i support this inquiry in the way the
home sector is set up because we want
urgent answers and urgent action how
does a veteran work in relation to
people joining the police service people
transferring between police services how
to ensure
there isn't a culture in the police
service whereby somebody who's worried
about the behavior of others
inappropriate behavior inappropriate
language involved confident reporting
and kicking out of the police service
those who aren't fit to be police
officers well the usual way that
organizations do go about this is
changing the way that those
organizations are led and and we've just
seen christopher dick being reappointed
you've described her as experienced and
a strong leader and have welcomed her
reappointment do you think the person
that was in charge while all of these
things
went wrong including the vetting and
we're not even going to talk about all
the other things that that she's been
involved in that there's been criticism
of
do you not think that it it is time for
her to step down one of the things
that's quite clear uh from all the uh
events i'm holding
uh is that replacing one person is not
going to address the serious issue we've
got in relation to the concerns being
raised not just in the police service
the hmi did a report very recently and
she used the word epidemic when
describing the issue of violence against
women and girls across our society it's
a reality
i'm afraid that between international
women's day last year
and this year 118 women were killed at
the hands of uh men and so we've got to
make sure of course
we get the police's house in order i
think as a society we've got to address
the issue of misogyny i think it should
be a hate crime i think the harassment
of women in a public place should be
criminal offense i think we're going to
start in primary school but i think
you're right we've got to make sure our
police services across the country
have the trust of confidence which i
think has been shattered
by the events of the last couple of
weeks but the conf there's no confidence
within the force as well though i spoke
to a female former officer just last
week um and she said on on the sarah
everard sentencing and she said that
that she would was scared to stand up to
males who'd misbehaved around her within
the force during the current leadership
because she didn't know if then when she
went out on a job if she got into
trouble they would back her up now i
mean that is no way to run an
organization is it if women within that
organization don't feel safe surely the
responsibility for that goes all the way
to the top
well i can't speak about the individual
ex-officer what i can say is part two
of the inquiry announced today from the
home secretary we'll look at just those
sorts of uh issue
are there procedures in place where
women in particular feel safe coming
forward with a grievance is the counter
corruption work fit for purpose is the
whistleblowing process is fit for
purpose are we creating an environment
in a culture where we want to join the
police service and not just stay in a
police service but we can make
progression all those are some of the
issues we have okay in part two but also
the hmi her majesty inspector the
independent office for police conduct
also have a role to play as well as this
independent chair who homosexual will be
appointed very shortly
okay so say in in a few months time when
we hope that this inquiry will end and
it won't just drag on forever
save in a few months time we discover
that the answer to those questions is no
that women don't feel safe within the
police force uh that they don't feel
they're able to to report upwards when
they see an appropriate behavior what
happens then we don't make changes we've
got to make sure no stone is left
unturned
in relation to making uh the police a
service that is free from racism but how
do you change it that that's my my
question you know it's
yes we need to find out exactly what's
going on but but how how does it change
how do you change something as huge as
the police force and the mentality of
the people working within it well
firstly we've got to ascertain the facts
not just in relation to this police
officer and sarah's awful murder but in
relation to the missed opportunities
then we've got to make sure all those
are addressed in relation to urgent
implementation of the recommendations
made by independent chair
then in relation to the wider practices
in the police service we've got to see
what the inquiry uncovers in relation to
practices across the country you and i
have been reading on a daily basis and
hearing on a daily basis from offices
across the country but also women let
down uh by the criminal justice system
women not feeling confident to report
crimes a huge issue of under-reporting
and those that do report uh crimes for
example rape and other serious offenses
the conviction rates are so so uh small
and that's why it's really important
this is a whole government approach we
can't just leave this all of the door
the police the issue of misogyny didn't
start with the police i won't end with
the police it's going to be not helped
by the police though is it clearly
listen nobody can talk about the awful
uh murder of sarah
and not you know agree that public
confidence has been uh shattered it is
simply indefensible
not just the actions of that police
officer but the apparent missed
opportunities uh it's not acceptable
indeed sadiq khan always got to talk to
you thank you for joining us on sky